living in bradford has changed like
cities across the uk
covered 19 is now part of everyday life
and the north of england not just riding
the second wave
but approaching the tipping point
as we face a chaotic winter the pm
hoping to keep things simple we are
today
simplifying standardizing and in some
places toughening
local rules in england by introducing
three levels
of copied alert medium with
existing national measures such as the
rule of six and the closure of
hospitality
at 10 pm high with extra measures
including a ban on indoor social
mixing between households or support
bubbles
and very high for places where without
further action the nhs will swiftly
be under intolerable pressure the exact
restrictions at this level very high
will be worked out with local leaders
along with tailored packages of support
but at a minimum at a minimum they will
sadly include
a ban on all social mixing between
households in private places
including gardens and pubs and bars
must close the majority of the country
will
for now be at medium
most areas currently under local
intervention
will be at high and from wednesday local
authorities
in the liverpool city region will move
to the very high
alert level you just said we must act
now
and yet the only part of the country
today
put under these much stricter rules is
the liverpool city region
why is your rhetoric on this
outstripping the reality of the measures
you're actually
introducing and is it because you're
struggling to take regional leaders with
you
we want to take local authorities uh
with us
if we can't get agreement then clearly
it is the duty of
of national government to take uh the
necessary action to
to protect the public and to protect
public health and we will
a coded threat to intransigent local
leadership if they won't work with him
he'll override them but only reluctantly
the prime minister
knows the damage these restrictions will
bring earlier telling the commons
he's no choice but to act now i take no
pleasure whatsoever
in imposing restrictions on these
businesses
many of which have gone to great lengths
to reopen
as safely as possible nor do i want to
stop people
enjoying themselves but we must act
to save lives but as the infection rates
ratchet up
so too does the criticism i'm now deeply
skeptical
that the government has actually got a
plan to get control of this virus
to protect jobs or regain public trust
we've tried to give the prime minister
benefit of the doubt but it increasingly
feels like the prime minister
is several steps behind the curve and
running to catch up with a virus
that he has lost control of long ago
a winter of restrictions a tough sell in
the commons
but it's a tough sell here too the pm
announcing a new covered alert system
200 miles away
in london today but in bradford and
other cities across the north of england
people have been living in local
lockdown since the end of july
and despite their sacrifices it's
getting worse
not better and the struggle for the
prime minister is going to be persuading
local leaders
and local communities not just to stick
with the current rules but perhaps go
even
further still the pm not yet turning the
screws on tougher measures for most of
the north
but how long will it be before places
like bradford
join liverpool with stricter rules many
in government worry that it's a question
of when
not if beth rigby sky news bradford